الجنرال بتريوس مرحبًا بكم في أه في
البرنامج، كل هذه الأشياء التي عرضتها للتو كل تلك
الأشياء التي كنا نشاهدها
هذا الأسبوع المخاطر في أه الشرق
الأوسط، هل أنت قلق الآن من أنها يمكن أن تبدأ في
الامتداد إلى
حرب أوسع، حسنًا، أعتقد أنك  يجب أن
أقلق كريستيان في الحقيقة بالطريقة التي
سأصف بها الوضع العالمي العام
أه هو أننا نواجه
تحديات أكثر عددا وتحديات أكثر تعقيدا
وأكثر خطورة
يمكن القول في أي وقت منذ نهاية
الحرب الباردة إن لم يكن نهاية  الحرب العالمية
الثانية أه، إنها حالة محفوفة بالمخاطر للغاية
كما وصفتها، لذلك
من الجيد أنك تعرف
اللغة الدرامية والمقارنة، لذلك من
وجهة نظرك من وجهة نظرنا، ما هو
الأكثر خطورة أو لا يمكنك
الفصل بينهما جيدًا، أعتقد أنه من الصعب
افصل بينهما لأنه في يوم ما
سيظهر أحدهما أكثر تحديًا في
الوقت الحالي من الآخر،
لكنني أعتقد أننا لا يمكن أن نغفل أبدًا عن
العلاقة الأكثر أهمية في
العالم، وهي بالطبع العلاقة
بين الولايات المتحدة والولايات المتحدة حقًا.  قاد
الغرب والصين أه هذا هو الذي
له التأثير الأكبر وهو أيضًا
الذي لديه أكبر
جانب سلبي محتمل إذا صح التعبير أه وهذه
العلاقة هي القضية المركزية
اليوم حتى كما هو واضح جدًا أه
الوضع في أوكرانيا  التحديات في
الشرق الأوسط الكبير أه
كوريا الشمالية أه التهديدات المستمرة
للمتطرفين الإسلاميين حول العالم
التهديدات السيبرانية كل هذه أه هذه
كلها لوحات إذا صح التعبير علينا أن
نبقي SPL يدور في وقت واحد لكن
اللوحة أكبر وأهم
أكثر من كل الآخرين هو ذلك مرة أخرى الذي
يمثل التحدي أه
للعلاقة بين الولايات المتحدة والغرب
والصين، لذلك اسمحوا لي أن أطلب منك فقط
توضيح ذلك لأنك تعلم أنه
قبل شهرين التقى الرئيسان الحادي عشر
وبايدن أه في كاليفورنيا وهناك
يبدو أنها بدايات ربما لنوع ما
من التهدئة بطريقة ما، لكن
الأحدث الآن هو أن الولايات المتحدة تعتقد أنها ترى أن
الصين تتحرك
لتحديث أو إعادة بناء مواقعها النووية
ولدينا عام انتخابي في تايوان
والذي يمكن أن يحدث بالفعل  آه، كما تعلم، قد
تكون هناك مشكلة إذا فاز
الفصيل المؤيد للاستقلال، وما
تراه هو أين ترى
نقطة انطلاق حسنًا، أولاً وقبل كل شيء، أعتقد أن
الاجتماع بين رئيسينا كان
مشجعًا بشكل متواضع للغاية، إنه
أفضل بكثير  غير أنه لا يحدث أه
الاجتماعات اللاحقة بين مختلف
النظراء وحكومتينا أه
المشاركة من قبل دول أخرى أه من
الغرب الأمريكي مع الصين هذا كله
جهد لمحاولة إنشاء أرضية
لعلاقة أه فيها في الآونة
الأخيرة إلى حد ما  حلقة EP عندما كان بالون تجسس
يطفو فوق الولايات المتحدة،
التقطنا الهاتف في البنتاغون
ولم يرد أحد في بكين، لذلك
أعتقد أن إجراء اتصالات مرة أخرى
تطور إيجابي ولكن هذا ليس
إيجابيًا للغاية، فهذه
بداية للجهد  بين
البلدين، مع الإشارة إلى أن العلاقة بيننا،
كمستشار للأمن القومي، وصفتها بأنها
علاقة
منافسة شديدة، وما يتعين علينا القيام به بالطبع
هو التأكد من أن عناصر
الردع قوية للغاية، حيث يقوم
الخصوم المحتملون بتقييم
قدراتنا من ناحية.
واستعدادنا لتوظيفها من ناحية
أخرى لا يمكن التشكيك فيه ولكننا بينما
نحتاج إلى أن نكون حازمين للغاية لا نريد أن
نكون استفزازيين بلا داع ولكن مرة أخرى
أعتقد أن التشجيع المتواضع للجهود المبذولة
لإعادة بناء
قدراتهم النووية لتوسيعها كان
مستمرة لفترة طويلة جدًا من الوقت،
ولكن مرة أخرى، أعتقد أن هذه الحلقات الأخيرة
متواضعة، مرة أخرى مشجعة، حسنًا،
حسنًا، دعنا نذهب إلى نوع
الأزمتين الكبيرتين اللتين تحدثان الآن،
حربان يتعين على الولايات المتحدة إدارتهما، كما تعلم
أنك قلت  بخصوص غزة، أم أنه
يجب على إسرائيل أن تمسك وتبني ماذا
تقصد بذلك، وأنت تعلم أن
هناك الكثير من الانتقادات الآن من
المبنى الأمريكي وحلفائه حول
عدد القتلى الضخم الذي
تكبدته إسرائيل بسبب المكافحة
الهجوم بعد المذبحة التي وقعت في
السابع من تشرين الأول (أكتوبر) هو
أكثر ما يقلقك بشأن كيفية
تطور الأمر بشكل جيد أولاً. أعتقد أن
السؤال هو ما إذا كانت إسرائيل قادرة على تحقيق
الهدف الذي حددته والذي
أتفق معه بالمناسبة، وأعتقد أن حماس
بحاجة إلى أن تكون كذلك.  أعتقد أن تدميره
يشبه تنظيم الدولة الإسلامية، وهو تشبيه غير كامل
بالنظر إلى العناصر الوطنية الفلسطينية
هنا، لكنني أعتقد أنه يجب
تدميره. وهذا أحد
الأهداف الرئيسية الثلاثة المعلنة لإسرائيل، والآخر
هو تفكيك الجناح السياسي وأنا
أتفق مع هذا الهدف  ومن الواضح
أن يتم إطلاق سراح رهائنهم أه
واستعادتهم ولكن طريقة القيام بذلك كما
ناقشنا أنا وأنت منذ البداية
هي التطهير والاحتجاز عن طريق فصل
أه السكان عن
المتطرفين أه وأنا لا أرى ذلك
يحدث أه  عبر غزة والآن
انسحاب خمسة ألوية من
قوات الدفاع الإسرائيلية هناك
أعتقد أنه يثير تساؤلات حول ما إذا كانت
إسرائيل قادرة بالفعل على تدمير حماس مرة أخرى
وتفكيك الجناح السياسي أه
وبالمناسبة أيضًا منع حماس من
إعادة التشكيل لأنه بالطبع هناك
بعض  هناك أفكار كبيرة إضافية كانت هناك
حاجة إليها منذ فترة طويلة، مثل ما تعرفونه عن
عملية ما بعد الصراع، ومن الذي
سيشرف على غزة، ولا توجد أي أيدي مرفوعة في
المنطقة، ومن المؤكد أنه لا يوجد
كيان فلسطيني كفؤ، وجدير بالثقة يمكن
إحضاره من الضفة الغربية، ويبدو
من خلال  بشكل افتراضي سيتعين على إسرائيل أن
تفعل ذلك وأعتقد
أنه كلما تم الاعتراف بهذه الحقيقة في
واشنطن قبلت ذلك أيضًا لأنه
لا يوجد بديل قابل للتطبيق إذا كنت
تريد التأكد من عدم قدرة حماس على
إعادة التشكيل أه فيجب
التخطيط وفقًا لذلك  ولكن قبل كل شيء، من
سيحصل على المساعدة الإنسانية الإضافية
التي يحتاجها
الناس بشدة، ما هي الرؤية
للناس أه الذين ينظرون إلى
الضفة الغربية أثناء وجودنا فيها ومن
سيشرف أه من سيصمد
ومن ثم إعادة البناء الإشراف على
إعادة الإعمار واستعادة
الخدمات الأساسية وإعادة فتح عيادات مدارس السوق
وما إلى ذلك لقد شعرت أنه
كان ينبغي أن يظل المستشفى مفتوحًا
على وجه الخصوص ولكن جميعهم وعلاج
المدنيين في هذه المستشفيات يسيطرون
عليهم مع التأكد من أن الأنفاق
مقرات تحتهم أو ما
يتم فيهم أه غير مسموح
أه ويتم القضاء عليه
ولكن مرة أخرى يجب عليهم توفير
الناس بدون
سؤال